- That's when Carlisle found me
dying a Spanish influenza.
- What was it like?
(grunting)
- The venom was excruciating.
(car horn honking)
(car wheels squeaking)
- Thank you.
Nice save.
(ominous music)
(gun shooting)
(grunting)
- Devon!
- Admit it,
you just wish you had the
balls to do it yourself.
(growling)
(ominous music)
- Not smart, little man.
(grunting)
- What do we do now?
- There will be no need to teach,
simply remain on my side and I shall
absolve you.
- I could be wrong, but I think
you were having a nightmare.
You do look rather pale.
- It's too late to fight back now.
(growling)
(screaming)
- No!
- Anyone, any time, any place.
(grunting)
(gasping)
(ominous music)
(screaming)
(grunting)
(growling)
(gasping)
- Sorry, Jasper is our newest vegetarian.
It's a little difficult for him,
- It's a pleasure to meet you.
- It's okay, Jasper,
you won't hurt her.
- All right,
I want to take you on a tour
of the rest of the house.
- Okay.
- Well, I'll see you soon.